I'm not crying you're crying shut up
it's onions I scratched my foot
emotional okay fine it was Coco the last
30 minutes of Coco hi my name is Tamara
chambers and this is Tamara just saw
pretty sure there's no spoilers in this
I'm gonna be talking at in depth well
for me in depth for me I'm gonna try not
to spoil anything other than tears are
involved today I went and saw Coco which
I have been looking forward to for quite
a long time I am loving this seeming
push from Disney to be more inclusive
and and represents more people and this
was such an obvious choice to go with I
won't be able to talk on the culture of
this movie and I won't be able to talk
on whether they got things right or
wrong in that aspect but I will be able
to talk on how it made me feel and it it
was a special movie y'all this is one of
my favorite Pixar movies in in recent
years I just had such a good time
watching this kid of Miguel work his way
through finding himself through music
and dealing with you know hardships with
family and and coming out on the other
end and seeing that family is what is
most important to him it was a slow game
though they really they built everything
up really well on concrete building
blocks to create this story that you
really cared about these characters that
you really cared about so beautiful and
heartwarming at the end it's not like an
up Pixar movie where you're just crying
from the get-go it's just it's
beautifully paced in a way that's like I
care about all of this I care about all
of us and then when the touching sad cry
worthy moments happen you're like oh
waiting for I I'm someone who loves to
cry in film I
love it it feels like such a release to
cry for like a character that I don't
know we're lucky characters I do know
but like a character and not like
real-life things anytime I want a good
cry I put on the episode of How I Met
Your Mother we're Marshalls dad dies or
I put on a walk to remember or sorry dad
with Moulin Rouge
something that is gonna make me cry and
it's cathartic as hell and this did not
disappoint
in that aspect it felt so true and pure
and earned I think it's super important
that there is representation for for
like children who are watching Disney
movies and Pixar movies I loved it guys
I loved it
damn damn coke coke damn my fake bangs
are not there they're not cooperating I
have big bangs in I think I first saw
the trailer for this and did it know how
to feel it didn't grab me immediately
they relied heavily on the dog character
Dante who is really cute ends up being
super fun super great in the film I
ended up loving Dante but maybe for the
trailer that was a mistake
for in my opinion it didn't really grab
me the story is about Miguel who is a
young boy in a long line of shoemakers
and way way back his great grandmother
started a shoe making business because
her husband left the family to be a
musician so the whole lineage of the
family has said no to music ever since
they don't want to hear it on the
streets they don't want to hear in the
household there's no singing you can't
even blow into a glass bottle to make
like all sound no music and Miguel has a
secret cubby hole in the top of this
Shack where he's made his own guitar
which is crazy hard so cute oh it's so
cute and he really looks up to I
yokas who is the greatest musician ever
made in the world he's the greatest
musician the character that he looks up
to his name is Ernesto de la Cruz and
he's played by Benjamin Bratt who I had
a giant crush on growing up because he
was in Miss Congeniality which Tuesday
is still an excellent film fight me he's
also a giant jerk in that film but
growing up I had a huge crush on him and
I he did great the voice acting in this
movie was just perfect which you
wouldn't expect less from Pixar it's
like saying that the animation is great
like it's just beautiful isn't even
animation at this point CGI right I
don't know I don't know how things work
its animation I'm sure but it's stunning
he first walks out into the land of the
dead and it's just like what huh what
you what what what how long did this
take it was absolutely study but that's
what you expect with Pixar now so I
won't even like brush up on that that's
just what it was the voice acting though
especially from the young actor who
plays in the gyal gotta look up his name
you gotta give credit where credit is
due
what Anthony Gonzales you stop her you
star Anthony Gonzales first of all
amazing acting like just acting his
pants off also his singing voice is so
precious and good and you just could you
could hear the smile that he had on when
he was saying these lines and seeing
these lines it was so good the story
itself though a little not predictable I
will say there were definitely surprises
I was definitely surprised in this film
though it is a little like not
lackluster what am I looking for it's
just kind of like standard maybe is I
don't know I feel like I've seen it
before but I haven't but I feel like I
have you know what I mean maybe not I
wonder what it is on Rotten Tomatoes not
that Rotten Tomatoes is the
say all of things but I'm always curious
96% audience score also 96% yes yes I
also think it's really incredible that a
lot of theaters are playing this in just
Spanish and Disney also made an app
where you can download it put the
earbuds in or something I actually don't
know how it works I saw this on a video
about it you can listen to it in all
Spanish which is the coolest thing I
think something that I've never thought
about ever is not being able to enjoy
movies with your your grandparents if
your grandparents don't speak English
you're like if your parents don't speak
English or like if you don't speak
English but especially if you do you
won't be able to enjoy that with your
family and that's a huge thing I just
never thought about like that's a family
thing that you do together
you like on Christmas like I go and see
movies with my family and like that's I
just never thought of it and I think
that's so flippin cool and even if you
don't care about representation at all
which you should but if you don't
whatever um it still just it's a really
cute wholesome beautiful touching film
that is worth seeing in theaters I think
I think the only thing going against
this film is that the trailers really
didn't capture me I wish that they had
because I feel like maybe other people
feel the same way but I mean I know that
because a couple people tweeted that at
me I tweeted today about to see Coco no
makeup
I hear tears are involved they were
spoiler and then Wow that was special go
see Coco I got some responses from
people being like I'm so glad that my
culture is being represented and and I'm
so glad that so many people are going to
be reached by this culture and also like
where's all this positivity coming from
I am shocked by the reviews that are
coming out because it didn't grab me in
the trailer and like what a bummer of a
thing damn damn baby I want to go see it
again right now I sat in the front
because I want to be away from from
everyone the theater was packed I saw
this at 11 a.m. on a Friday
how is this packed it was packed which
is so exciting
but anyway so everyone behind me you can
hear sniffles you can hear like the
young children being wait what just
happened like you know asking K
questions in movies and it didn't even
it didn't bother me at all and then at
the end the whole theater erupts with
with clapping and applause so happy
fills my heart with joy
I can't fills me with joy this is Pixar
so people will definitely see it but I
just want everyone to see it I want
everyone to go and see this film I go
man whoo also Olaf's rows of adventure
thank you
pretty cute I think the movie started up
and I was like already touched by Olaf's
frozen fucking adventure anyway thank
you so much for watching y'all I think
next week is disaster artist question
mark I cannot wait for that film never
underestimate the power of music no one
was gonna hand me my future it was up to
me to reach for my dream grab it tight
and make it come true Ernesto de la Cruz
[Music]